(cheerful music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting.
We're talking about
life, post-vaccination.
We're talking about,
"When I'm fully vaccinated, I'm gonna..."
Fill in that big, old blank.
- And we're both, half
vaccinated.
- Half-vaxxed.
As of this recording.
- And soon to be fully Vaxxed.
- And so we're going to talk about
the excitement and anticipation
and then the re-entry into
more of normal life,
or just how we've anticipated
that in our brains
versus the reality of
starting to carry that out
and also talking about a
phenomenon called re-entry anxiety.
(Rhett grunts)
- So--
- And we're not talking
about space travel?
- No I'm talking about--
- Or sorting the mail?
(Link guffaws)
- No, no.
Not talking about that.
But yeah, so I think, you know,
there's kind of a dark side
to getting on with our lives,
having been vaccinated.
- Yeah.
- And of course, that's not to say,
you know, we're recording this
and then releasing it a few weeks later.
So just in full disclosure--
- We're always a little
bit ahead of the game.
- There's some things that
we're not as current as possible
and things change and update so quickly,
that I just wanna put that out there.
- Yeah.
And you know what?
Because we're talking about vaccines,
there is a lot of vaccine
hesitancy out there, right?
So, you know, me,
I can't just,
I can't just move along.
(Rhett guffaws)
I can't just get my vaccine
and not say anything about it.
So, here's what I wanted to do
before we get into the
rest of the episode.
- Yeah.
- I wanted to make my vaccine pitch.
My pitch for why I think
you should get the vaccine.
I got it and I think
that you should get it,
if you're not in a risk
group and if you qualify.
- There's a lot of
information floating around
and it sways people.
- Yeah.
- Most people like me,
you just wanna make a decision
and get on with your life.
And, you know, I don't go on Facebook.
I don't do...
I find myself avoiding engaging
in a lot of the information
and the deep dives
because it stresses me out
and I just want to get on
with it and move past this.
And that's not necessarily
a healthy thing,
but I know that there's a lot
of people like me out there
that are...
They haven't gotten vaccinated
and they don't know if they are,
but just looking at the information
and all the conflicting
opinions is very intimidating,
overwhelming, anxiety-inducing
and you just wanna curl
up in a ball and avoid it.
- We live in a very interesting time
where it is legitimately very
difficult to move forward
with decisions like this without at least
some sort of hesitancy because
of the way the information
and misinformation spreads, right?
- And because there's so much attachment
to what these decisions
mean about who you are,
who you're affiliated with,
what your core beliefs are.
- Everything has been politicized.
It's very--
- Yeah.
- It's loaded.
All these decisions and
perspectives are so loaded.
- Yeah, well, here's
what I'm gonna try to do.
I'm gonna try to put this...
And again, I'm not a
scientist, I'm not a doctor.
You already knew that.
I'm a guy who eats weird
things on the internet
and has a podcast with his best friend.
Hi Link.
- Hey!
- But I am a concerned citizen.
And I've been thinking about this in a way
that I hope can cut through
a lot of the numbers and the
arguments and a lot of things
that can get kind of
confusing and misleading
and just kinda talk to you as a friend.
Now, first of all,
if you think that the
medical establishment
is an extension of the Deep State
and the vaccine campaign is a scheme
to inject microchips into
people, to control them,
this pitch is not for you, okay?
You can fast forward,
or you're probably not listening already,
but if you are listening,
I do have something for you at the end,
so please stick around.
- Ooh!
- This is my pitch for those
of you who are on the fence.
You have reservations about the vaccine.
You've heard about the side effects.
What about those blood clots?
Why aren't these vaccines
developed really quickly?
How do you know that
they're safe long-term
and by the way, COVID,
isn't that dangerous?
Why would I get a vaccine
with unknown side effects
when I'd probably be fine if I got COVID?
If you thought anything
like that, this is for you.
Okay, so let's start with
the ultimate purpose of the vaccine.
The vaccine is not primarily
about protecting you
individually from the virus.
Vaccines are our best available tool
for eliminating disease
across a population.
In this case, all of humanity.
This is how we end a disease.
So, framing the decision
around your own personal risk
is kind of missing the point.
This isn't about you as
much as it's about us.
It's not a me thing.
It's a we thing.
Now, speaking of the we thing.
If we don't reach herd immunity,
there's a real risk of
COVID continuing to evolve
and form variants and we're
gonna be dealing with this
for a very long time.
The more people who get the vaccine,
the more likely we beat it.
And even if we don't reach
herd immunity, which,
given the vaccine hesitancy
and the limited rollout around the world,
there's a very real possibility
we will not reach herd
immunity as we would like to,
but even so, more vaccines mean
less of a problem with COVID
for everybody down the line.
So, it's not like a
lost cause by any means.
Now you may have heard
that the vaccines don't stop
infection, or transmission,
but they only lessen the symptoms.
And you might be asking, "Well,
why do I have to wear a mask
"after I get vaccinated?"
Well, scientists are actually
very hesitant to make claims
until they have good data.
It's kinda their thing.
But they're getting a
lot of data very quickly.
And the latest data indicates
that these new vaccines,
not only prevent severe
COVID and hospitalization
almost completely, but
they also very likely
prevent infection as well as transmission.
Therefore, the hesitancy
to move beyond masks
and social distancing has been
because we wanna make sure
that that is the case, okay?
That's a big part for that.
A big part of that.
But what about the risks?
This seems to be the thing
that most people talk about.
What about the risks?
Specifically the thing
that I hear a lot is,
if the mortality rate of COVID is so low,
is it worth taking the risk
of getting the vaccine?
Well, the mortality rate
of COVID isn't that low.
There are a lot of factors
and data's still coming in,
but COVID is likely, at least 10 times,
more deadly than the flu.
But, I'll give it to you.
Even if you get it especially
if you're not in a risk group,
you very likely will not die from COVID.
Now for me, a healthy dude,
not that young, 43,
but I'm not in a risk group,
I don't have risk factors,
but it's the long-term
complications from COVID
that are the most
concerning to me personally.
Long-term symptoms
affect people of all ages
and have occurred in
people with mild, moderate
and severe COVID-19.
These can include lung
damage, heart damage,
lasting fatigue, joint pain,
neurological disorders,
loss of taste and smell, sleep disorders.
And these are showing up
in significant numbers.
Okay, but, okay, I get that.
But what about the risks of the vaccines?
Well, let's start with the blood
clots from the J&J vaccine.
The Johnson and Johnson
vaccine 'cause that's what,
at least right now, as
we're recording this,
that's what everybody's talking about.
Six people out of about 7
million who were vaccinated
developed blood clots.
And as of today, as of recording this,
one of those people has died.
That's horrible.
That's upsetting.
But just to put that into perspective,
it's about one in a million
chance of getting a blood clot
and a one in 7 million chance of dying
from a blood clot from the J&J vaccine.
To put that into perspective,
you're much more likely
to die in a car accident on
the way to get the vaccine
than you are to get a blood
clot from the vaccine,
much less die from the vaccine.
But keep in mind they still
paused the J&J vaccine
in many places because of this risk
because the scientists are
actually very concerned
with safety, so much so when there's this
statistical blip on the
radar they stop to evaluate.
They're not trying to
take advantage of you.
use you as guinea pigs.
They're actually showing that
safety is their number one priority.
Okay, but that's J&J.
That's only a small
percentage of the vaccines.
What about mRNA?
The Moderna, which is what I got
and the Pfizer which is what you got?
- Hm mm.
- This stuff's unproven, right?
I mean, we are just a bunch of guinea pigs
being experimented on.
Well, we have a lot of
good reasons to believe
that mRNA vaccines are safe.
Likely safer than traditional vaccines
for a number of reasons.
So, they underwent
some of the most rigorous
safety testing ever.
Fast, quick, yes, but
rigorous nonetheless.
- Hm mm.
- But what about the long-term risks?
Well, these vaccines are
actually not that new.
Trials were conducted
for mRMA vaccines in 2009
for prostate cancer, 2013 for rabies
and mRMA vaccines were
already in clinical trials
for HIV, cancer and Zika-patients
before the development
of the COVID vaccines
and nothing found in those
trials led to hesitancy
to move forward with COVID-19 vaccines.
This isn't something that was just pulled
out of the back pocket
of scientists and doctors
in response to this pandemic.
It was something they had been working on
for quite some time.
And the mechanism of mRNA vaccines
is a new approach to vaccines,
but it's actually really straightforward
and there are lots of
advantages, including safety.
Now, there's a lot of
misinformation about this,
but messenger-RNA
doesn't get anywhere near
the nucleus of the cell
that contains human DNA.
And it disintegrates
quickly after the message
that it is communicating, is read.
It does not alter your DNA
because it cannot alter your DNA.
Now you may have read on the
internet about scary things
like antibody dependent enhancement,
the idea that getting these
vaccines is gonna cause you
to actually have a higher
chance of dying down the line
from getting COVID-19,
especially a variant,
or that there are
ingredients in the vaccine
that might cause cancer.
All of this was taken into account
when developing the vaccine
and there is no reason to believe
that these are risks from the vaccines.
Just plain and simple.
There's a lot of good
literature on all of this
and how these things were studied in depth
throughout the development,
including the antibody
dependent enhancement,
which is something I see a
lot of people talk about.
Now, does that mean that
nobody will have adverse,
short-term, or long-term
complications from the vaccine?
Of course not.
People are going to have adverse
reactions to this vaccine.
And with so many people being vaccinated,
we're going to see significant,
statistically small,
but significant because anything
that happens to a person
is significant and worrying
in some people right?
The most common adverse reaction
is gonna be an allergic reaction.
That's kinda what we've seen so far,
but we have every reason to believe
that the long-term
complications from COVID itself
pose a much higher risk.
So here's the bottom line.
The only way to justify vaccine hesitancy
as it relates to vaccine risk
compared to the risk of COVID itself,
is to drastically overestimate
the risk of the vaccines,
while drastically underestimating
the risk of COVID itself.
Do you see what I'm saying there?
People who have hesitancy
about the vaccine
tend to also diminish what
the real risks of COVID are.
It's kinda like saying,
"I'm not gonna go on
that flight to California
"to free solo climb the face of El Capitan
"because flying is dangerous."
Or maybe a better example.
Lots of people who are scared of flying
have absolutely no problem
driving to the airport,
even though they're way more
likely to die in the car
on the way to the
airport than in the plane
on the way to their destination.
This is an irrational fear
based on risk perception,
not actual risk.
And the same thing is
happening with a lot of people
who are getting the vaccine.
Who are not getting the vaccine.
Same thing is happening
with a lot of people
who are not getting the vaccine.
So, in summary.
Step one, properly
framing the issue is key.
Assessing whether, or not
you should get the vaccine
should be framed first
as a community issue,
not as a personal one.
The collective risk to
everyone is much higher
when you don't get the vaccine.
In step two, you've gotta
properly frame the risk.
We have good reason to believe
that your personal risk
from getting the vaccine
is significantly less
than your risk from acquiring COVID
and experiencing adverse effects.
Now, this is still taking
into account the fact
that you voluntarily get the vaccine,
but you won't know necessarily get COVID.
You see what I'm saying?
People are like, "Well, I've
not choose to get COVID,
"but I'm choosing to get the vaccine.
"Doesn't that inherently increase
the risk of the vaccine?"
No, the COVID risk is still greater
just being a person
who lives in the world.
So, even if you're thinking
about this as an individual,
it still makes sense for
you and your personal safety
to get the vaccine.
So please, for all of us, get the vaccine.
Now, if you're a conspiracy theorist,
thank you for sticking around.
- That's why I've just
been hanging out here.
- You may be wondering why
I took this time in our
sometimes comedy podcast,
usually comedy podcast
(Link grunts)
to put together this message.
I'm gonna come clean.
I'm a part of the Deep State.
I'm being personally paid by Dr. Fauci,
who is a friend of mine,
who has my Venmo account,
to communicate this message
on behalf of the Deep State,
to the end of being able
to control as many people
as we possibly can in
the long-term future.
Dr. Fauci and I regularly
attend, sorry Link,
I'm letting you know this
for the first time as well--
- Yeah, I'm--
- Regularly attend--
- Kinda floored.
- Hollywood parties together,
at least we did before COVID.
We look forward to going
back to those parties,
where mainly the thing that we
do, I mean, there's cocktails
and there's mingling,
but we kind of do that
for like 90 minutes and then
we all go to the basement
and that's when we do the real good stuff,
which is drink the blood of children.
Now you may be wondering
how do I have such good
skin at the age of 43?
It's not some sort of
face washing and, you
know, exfoliation routine.
It's regularly drinking
the blood of children.
- How is that?
- It's kind of metallic taste.
- Okay.
- But we put it through a Brita.
- Oh.
- And you still get the
stuff that you need.
The adrenochrome.
- Gotcha.
- If you wanna stay young,
if you wanna be in control,
if you wanna be on the side of the people
who are gonna win in the
future, join me and Dr. Fauci.
Drink the blood of children.
You heard it here.
- And yet I haven't been invited.
Okay, cool.
- I didn't think
you were ready yet.
(laptop slides on desk)
- Okay, there it is.
The laptop's going away.
You know, I appreciate you
organizing those thoughts
and putting that out into the world
because it's easy to be
overwhelmed by information.
I think a lot of it has to do with
people making decisions
based on who do they trust
and why and what do you
really want, personally.
Like, what are your
motives and your values
and how do those things
all add up, you know?
So, there's a lot of people
who are just, it's just...
It really comes down for a lot of people,
and I think this is my experience
a lot of times, it's just,
who are you following?
Who are you trusting?
- Yeah.
And why?
Really, why?
- Well, we could do.
We could do, not necessarily
a podcast, but a whole show
on how you choose
where you get your information from
and what the point of that
is and if you can trust.
I mean, first of all, some of
the numbers that I threw out
and the statistics and the data,
I know there's a lot of
people who are just like,
"Well, you just believe
all the propaganda data."
"You don't believe the real data
"which I can find on the internet."
Again, that's such a pervasive problem
in our society right now,
there's nothing I'm gonna be able to say
that's gonna sway you on that.
The only thing I can ask is
just continue to be open-minded
and self-critical.
You know, I'm not gonna try
to change your mind on that.
I'm just gonna joke about Dr. Fauci.
Well, I'm not joking though.
It's true.
I drink the blood of children.
I wanna make that clear.
- All right, so let's shift
gears a little bit into,
what now?
We've made our decisions.
We're about to, you
know, in a couple of days
I'm gonna get that second dose in my arm
and then I got two weeks later
and then I'm totally free!
And this is what I've
been looking forward to
since the very beginning of lockdown.
And then, you know.
So, I think there is an
evolving set of guidelines
associated with what you can and can't
and should and shouldn't do
once you're fully vaccinated.
So, disclaimer at this point, again
this is three weeks old
even the moment it comes out
because of when we're having
to record this conversation.
So, we defer and direct you
to the latest and greatest guidelines
that we are not giving here,
in what to do and not do
when you are fully vaccinated, okay?
- Having said that,
- So.
- I think we can safely assume,
or for the purposes of this conversation,
so we don't have to keep
coming back to that point,
I think that the way that I'm
thinking about this question
is,
I'm just kind of saying, if things were to
suddenly get back to normal and I was able
to do all the things that I did before,
how do I perceive those things
and what am I thinking about those things,
whether that be going to a
movie, or a concert, or whatever.
I don't know exactly when
those things are gonna happen,
but I'm just saying for the
purposes of this conversation
I'm thinking about like the next year
and the freedoms that might come back.
- Yeah.
And so, let's start in that
positive aspirational place.
And then I'm sure we'll talk about
the anxiety flip side of that
and kinda dealing with that.
And even some of that I've personally
had a taste of already
and it surprised me.
But let's just start at the...
I mean, what are the first
things, just like throw out
words.
- Restaurants.
- Right, okay.
For me--
- That's a big one for me.
- Movies.
I haven't been to a movie.
- Movies, yeah, I'm on board with movies.
- And one last.
And we'll come back
to all this
- Concerts.
- Yeah.
In a way that I've never
felt about concerts before,
I'm like, "Now's the time.
"I'm gonna be that concert guy."
(Rhett chuckles)
- Yeah.
- Extended family visits.
Going back home to North Carolina.
- Parties.
- Parties?
Okay, now you're really getting into it.
- Parties with people that you know
and parties with people
that you don't know.
- Wow!
- There's two kinds
of parties.
- Okay.
- So, I'm talking get togethers
and then I'm talking, like, parties.
I'm talking about me and
Fauci in the basement.
With drinking
(Link chuckles)
the blood of children with a stranger--
- Uh mm.
- And not worried
about anything.
Especially the children.
I don't know how many times
I'm gonna keep coming back to that
'cause I know it's offensive to people,
but I just can't help it.
- I'm really tempted
to just keep going
- I can't help it.
- harder in it, but I don't wanna do it.
- People are just gonna, I mean.
Hmm.
(Rhett inhales deeply)
- By the way, totally unrelated.
We've got our
- Have the same,
- friendship rings on today.
- Same, same ring, yeah.
- Look at that, right?
Hold up, hold up your hand there.
Look at that.
Friendship ring day.
This is a previous sponsor.
We have not discussed this.
And so as a total aside--
- Hm mm.
- I feel like we need to get
this out of the way, okay?
We are wearing the exact same ring.
- It was a sponsor, "Manly Bands."
We might as well say it again.
- Right.
- And one of the stipulations,
not stipulations,
but one of the opportunities,
- Well, we're gonna--
- was you get to get a ring from--
- Well, I'm not gonna promote something
unless I can experience it
- Yeah.
- and know that I wanna promote it.
- But you,
- So, yeah.
- You requested
- Well.
- just the silicone ring.
'Cause they had like the,
basically like a rubber ring,
that you can wear when you're
doing activities and stuff.
A lot of people wear them full time.
So, you don't have to worry about your.
We know some people who've
gotten their fingers taken off
because of wedding rings.
- 'Cause the ring got hung on something.
- But you're like.
I wear...
There's a lot of sentimental value
with the ring that you have
because it was your grandfather's ring,
so you're not gonna take that off.
- No, I'm not gonna replace
my wedding band.
- So, you asked
for the silicone ring and I was like,
well I just bought my wedding
ring for like 200 bucks
before we got married,
I'll keep it around, but
I've always wanted to have
a wooden ring because
you know me and wood.
- That's not how I remember
it at all right, Rhett.
(Rhett guffaws)
- You have a tendency to.
You have a revisionist brain.
You have a super revisionist brain.
- Just because we disagree about something
doesn't mean that you're
the one that's right.
(Rhett guffaws)
So let's be clear on that.
And we do have a witness.
(indiscernible)
- Are you gonna tell me--
- I'm gonna tell you--
- Are you about to tell me
that you chose that ring?
- No, Imma tell...
Imma gonna say, okay, we were given it...
These are pricey rings.
They're gonna send one as a sample,
but they're not gonna send two.
That's what we were told.
- True that.
- So, then it was like, "Oh,
well, who gets the ring?"
- But that was when
- And then--
- you said you didn't want
to change your wedding ring
because it has sentimental value.
- That didn't mean I didn't want a ring.
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- Exactly because then you
just said what ring you wanted.
- But I was like,
I'm happy to change my ring.
- And then I'm like,
you know what?
And then I'm like, you know what,
If I really wanted a
ring, this'll be the point
where I would say, "I'd like
to try out a nice ring,"
but I elected not to.
And then you were like,
"Oh, they have wood rings."
So then you chose this ring that we both
are wearing.
(Rhett chuckles)
- Okay, that's the part I thought
you were taking
- And I was like,
"You know what?
"I'm interested," I was like,
"Do they have one of those rings
"that won't rip your finger off?
"A rubber ring?
"I'll take one of those
'cause they're cheap
"and we'll try it."
Now, by the way,
at this point having gotten a
sample that we did not pay for
I will gladly pay for another one,
but I did not pay for
this one to match you.
What happened was, the
ring that you ordered came
and it was too small.
I don't know.
You screwed up the sizing.
- Yeah, I did.
- Your fault, not the sponsors.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because instead of sizing, we told them
what we thought my size was.
- And then I'm like, "I bet
it would fit my finger."
So the ring that was too small for you
fit perfectly on my finger
and then I had it
- On your right hand.
- and you didn't have one.
- Right.
But then you ordered another
one 'cause you really wanted it
even though now we got,
I had no idea, I was like,
(Link chuckles)
I got him.
I know he's not gonna love this.
We have friendship rings now.
- So you're gonna keep wearing that?
- Yeah, and I'm gonna call
it our friendship ring.
- And while we're talking
about rings
- Because I know you.
(Links chuckles)
I know that makes you
- while we're talking
- a little uncomfortable.
- about rings, I'd been
wearing the aura ring.
You know, this is
basically a fitness ring.
It measures biometrics.
It is a fashion statement,
but that wasn't my primary
reason for wearing it.
- Oh, I ordered one of those too.
So we'll have double
- Well, yeah,
- friendship rings.
- but we both have new
aura rings coming.
And so the question is
- Yeah, we're gonna have,
- we're gonna have two rings
that are the same?
- That's--
- We should have gotten--
- I think that's kinda cool.
- We should have gotten
different because there's
multiple options for aura rings.
We should have gotten.
Maybe they'll send us two different kinds.
- Oh, we'll look into that.
Okay, sorry for the aside.
But yeah, I enjoy having a
friendship ring with you.
Don't you?
- I'm sorry
that I accused you of--
- Don't you?
- You have a revisionist mind,
but I thought what you were saying was,
you were gonna say is
that you chose this ring
and I was like, "Hold on a second.
"No, you didn't."
- You knew I wasn't gonna
replace my wedding ring,
so you assumed that I didn't want a ring
and I have nine other fingers,
that's all I'm saying.
- But I didn't know you
were gonna start doing
the multiple rings on hands thing
because I kinda just started doing it.
- Oh, see that's your--
(Rhett guffaws)
And I'm saying, you know what?
Multiple rings can't be your thing.
- Okay, and I agree with that.
Just like glasses can't be your thing.
- And beards can't be yours.
(Rhett guffaws)
We are gonna morph
into one person.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Listen, I don't have an appointment yet,
but I just wanna go ahead
and give you a fair warning
that glasses...
The last time I went to the
eye-doctor, over two years ago,
I was told that I needed glasses,
but then--
- And you haven't gotten them
because I'm the guy with glasses,
but you're starting to
send me over the precipice
'cause I've noticed
how big you want things that
we need to read blown up
and I'm like--
- Hmm, right.
- That's kinda getting to be too much.
- Yeah.
- I mean, the dude really can't see
if they're having--
- I'm having trouble.
I'm having trouble seeing.
- Okay, so back to post-pandemic.
Let's go back through these things.
The first thing that came
to my mind was movies.
And then right when I'm on
the precipice of scheduling.
And I'm telling the kids, I'm like,
"I don't even care what movie it is."
- Right.
- Like, I'll see
that King Kong vs Godzilla if I have to.
- Right.
- Even though I have
no interest whatsoever in seeing it,
I just wanna be in a movie theater.
And you know, someone told
me, when I got to this point
in the conversation with them, they said,
"You know you can rent out a
whole theater now because...
"I mean you gotta pick a slower time
"and just have all your friends show up."
I'm like, "No, no, no!
"I wanna be where everyone's strangers.
"I wanna do the old thing.
I don't wanna do this rent
out the theater thing.
And I don't care what movie it is.
And I know exactly where I'm gonna go.
My favorite theater,
- Uh mm.
- ArcLight Cinemas, the only
theater at the highest standard
where they charge the same amount,
no matter if you're a kid or whatever.
So it deters.
There's so many reasons besides just
not incentivizing bringing more kids
in a disproportionate amount.
- And for those of you who
are not from Los Angeles
and haven't been to Los Angeles,
haven't been to an ArcLight Cinema,
just a quick little summary
of why they're the best, okay?
- It is more expensive.
- They--
- But they control
every aspect
of the environment.
- What,
are you gonna control the conversation?
(Rhett laughs)
- Well, it's kind kinda
my thing, you know.
It's my favorite theater.
- Well, it's also my favorite theater.
Can I have a
favorite theater too?
- No!
(Rhett laughs)
No!
You can't have the same favorite theater.
- It's everyone's favorite theater
in Los Angeles.
- Go ahead.
- They bring someone out before the show.
You know how sometimes
you're at a movie theater
and it's not loud
enough, or it's too loud,
or it's not in focus?
And then you're like,
(Rhett clicks tongue)
"Am I gonna have to be
the person to get up
"and miss part of this
movie and go tell the guy
"who's serving popcorn that
they need to tell the guy
"who's running the thing in the thing
"that this is not working?"
- No.
- That doesn't happen
at ArcLight.
They bring a person out
who greets you, everyone
and says, "Hey, my name's Daryl.
"Welcome to this showing
of King Kong vs Godzilla."
"It's a great film.
"I enjoyed it."
- This is how long it lasts.
This is how long the
previews are gonna be.
- And I'm going to be
standing over here to the side
to make sure that the
picture and the sound quality
are perfect before we move on.
- Yes.
- They do it.
So you don't have to talk to the doofus
who's serving popcorn.
Not everybody who serves
popcorn is a doofus.
It's just in my experience,
I've had to go talk
to a doofus before, about this
and that's why I'm frustrated.
- And you know what?
- That doesn't happen
at the ArcLight.
- And it literally is the first thing
I've been looking forward to doing.
- And if you take your phone
out and text at the ArcLight,
you will be--
- There's a laser that
comes from behind the screen
and it will obliterate you.
- Yeah, yes.
You will be murdered.
You're just, yeah, you're taken out.
- Right.
- Because that inhibits everyone
else's experience, okay.
If you care about film,
or should I say cinema.
- But they bring in clone
- We care about this.
- of the person
So if you're there
- No one ever knows.
with loved ones
- Yeah.
- and you're really enthralled
in the movie and somebody
pulls out the phone,
yes, they're obliterated,
but they're immediately
- Yeah.
replaced with a clone.
- And their phone is gone though.
- All of these reasons make
it the number one thing
I've been looking forward to.
And they just went under.
(Rhett laughs)
- All this conversation about them--
- They waited until the end
of the pandemic,
literally right now, to
announce, "Oh, you know what?
"Can't do it anymore, guys.
"Can't hang on any longer.
"We're gone,"
like weeks before everyone can start.
I don't understand the
timing and I'm so frustrated.
- And not just ArcLight.
- Now I gotta find
another theater that I'm
willing to watch movies in.
- Not just ArcLight
but because Pacific
theaters bought ArcLight.
Pacific theaters, which I
think is the theater that's at
the Americana.
That's not opening either.
- Crap.
Oh, well, I think then other
companies will have to come in
and still make
them movie theaters
- Because they're still there.
What are they going to turn it into,
like a jump gym?
- But--
- Like one of those
trampoline places?
(Link sighs heavily)
- So--
- They gotta still
make movies there.
- I literally don't...
I now I have to find a new
movie experience 'cause I was
exclusive to them.
- I've heard
there's still reason for hope.
That there might be...
- Yeah.
- Jesse said it had something to do with,
this is a thing that happens.
I think that there are also a
lot of people in Los Angeles
who are making a huge
stink of this already
because this is film town.
- Maybe, maybe.
- We all stay through the
credits at the end of the movie.
It's a super film snob town
because this is where so many movies
are made.
- Okay, maybe there's hope--
- And so I think that we may
come together as a community
and say we don't just wanna
watch movies at our houses.
We don't wanna just watch movies
at theaters where they
don't have it in focus,
or it's not loud enough.
- Yeah.
- We wanna watch movies
at the ArcLight.
- Okay, I'll hold out a little hope.
It's kinda like that thing
where a company goes bankrupt
and then like a few months
later they're still around.
- Right.
- It's like, what, what?
Some sort of tax
- Like Trump.
- Ploy?
- Yeah.
- What happened?
- So that was literally my number one.
If you were to put your number one, is it
restaurants?
- No, it's not number one.
It's not number one because I
really like my new television.
You know, I finally did the
- Yeah.
- I finally did the 4K OLED
television.
- Yeah.
So what is your number one?
- Eating.
I mean restaurants.
- Restaurants.
- And there's just something
about eating at a restaurant
versus getting takeout from a restaurant.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, I've really forgotten.
I think I'm gonna go to
a restaurant and be like,
"Oh yeah, this should
have been my number one."
The food tastes so much better.
We supported our favorite
restaurants locally
and they'd send you their
signature dishes deconstructed,
- Yeah.
- so that everything
doesn't over melt together.
- You lose the presentation of the food.
And many times you lose
the freshness of the food
'cause it's coming to you in a bag.
You also lose, a big part of it for me,
is just the ambience.
I mean, for me eating is about
all the senses being stimulated, right?
And I love eating at restaurants.
I'd love the entire experience.
And yes, I understand
that there are restaurants
that are open for outdoor dining
and that they're socially
distanced dining--
- We haven't doing that.
- Right, so because we've been following
heightened protocols
associated with production
so that our limited crew,
we can all protect each other and continue
you know, making our shows.
- Our standards are higher
than just the general
California standards
which are already higher
than the general sort
of national standard.
- So we're admittedly behind.
- Yeah.
But even in my own brain
I've locked off the restaurant zone
because it hurt too
much after a few months
at the beginning of the
pandemic to dwell on it.
So now I'm finding it difficult
to reopen those compartments.
But I think when I go to a restaurant
the other part I miss
is that, yes, you still
got the whole phone
situation in your pocket,
but how it sets the stage for connection
you stare across the table at somebody,
me and Christie on a date,
a date is much different
out than trying to
recreate it in your own home.
Matter of fact, we just
got to a point where
we thought we were going
to do the date thing
and then it just didn't happen.
- Yeah, we did it.
We held on for a little bit.
- It just didn't happen.
- We did a thing for a
while where we would,
I would turn the lights
down, put on some music
and we would eat at our
little sort of breakfast nook.
And then we would make the
kids eat in a different room
or like eat in the dining room and--
- Right?
- I don't know, it worked for a while,
but it's just so hard to
maintain the separation
and the discipline.
- Yeah.
And then you're still doing
the dishes and the preparation.
- Yeah, right.
- Even if you order out.
- Yeah.
You know, it's like just being waited on
in a restaurant is so awesome.
- And yeah, I mean, I
love the experience--
- And it's like, I mean, I'm
starting to get excited now.
Cause it's like, I mean I think
I'm going to be at a restaurant
and I'm gonna be like,
"Wow, I feel like a King!"
Like, there'll be just
this renewed appreciation
for the whole thing.
Look, someone's coming up,
and just anything I want,
well and I can just tell this stranger
and they'll go away and
they'll come back with it!
- And that's why, I mean,
one of the many reasons
that the cost of living
in Los Angeles is so high,
you know compared to North
Carolina for instance,
is the event, like we're
so close to so many things
including so many great places to eat.
Like there's just so
many, you can never eat
at the same place twice
and keep having these
completely dynamic excellent
dining experiences.
Now I'm not saying you can't get it--
Well, maybe one of your
favorite things in LA.
- Yeah.
- As well.
- It's, I mean, it's one
of the things I'm like
when I think about how much
money I paid to live here,
I'm like, you kind of have
to start reminding yourself
of the advantages, because
especially one of the reasons
there's been this mass Exodus
of people from Los Angeles
during the pandemic is
because they're like,
if all I'm doing is hanging out at home,
why am I going to be in this
tiny little expensive place
when I can go to a less
expensive, larger place
and have the same experience, right?
I totally get it.
I dunno, we're not moving because
we've built our lives here
and we built our business
here but it's like,
I'm ready to experience the city
that I'm paying so much for.
- Well, I mean, I came so
close to buying a van that,
you know, I wouldn't have lived out of it,
but I would travel in semi-live
out of it on little trips.
And,
(Link guffaws)
that's taken a back burner now.
It's like, I can rent somebody else's van
whenever I want to do that.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
So that's the update on that aspiration.
It was, I had the tunnel
vision of the pandemic goggles,
you know, and I'm, I'm
gonna rent a van again.
Imma, trust me.
I'm gonna do it, but I'm not, I don't
I'm pretty sure I'm not going to buy one.
- The other aspect of this is parties.
Now again--
- Before we get to par--
- Let's go with the friends.
Cause I think that's
the incremental thing--
- That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying,
there's two aspects of this.
And so I'm saying that the first part
which I've experienced a little bit of
is getting together at
people's homes, right.
Now, very recently.
- Yep.
- So we got together
with another well, okay.
So there's a couple that
was fully vaccinated,
Jesse and I are, you know,
Jesse's fully vaccinated now,
I'm half vaccinated.
And you know, once you're a few weeks out
from the initial dose of
these Moderna or Pfizer,
you're very well-protected, especially if
you're around other people
who are vaccinated, right?
And so we made, so
there's we see each other
and we see this one other family,
but there was a friend who
we hadn't seen in over a year
who was at this family's house
and texted us and said,
"Hey, I'm over here."
"I'm fully vaccinated."
- I'm fully vaccinated.
- They're totally cool if guys come over
and it was a Friday night and--
- It was probably, it was like
it was like 7:30 or 8 pm.
- It was like eight.
I already, here's the thing.
I already, I had my plan.
And my plan was we were
going to watch a movie
and I don't remember what it
was, but I had it picked out.
And then we got the texts and I was like,
"Ah, I kind of had this plan,
"but I haven't seen
this person in a year."
Yes, let's go.
And we go over there.
And I mean, again, there's like hugs,
first thing was we're hugging.
This is a little bit unusual, right?
Just, I haven't hugged a lot of people--
- Yeah.
- In a long time!
- Now you're not a hugger.
So when that happened,
what was your experience?
Because there are people who are huggers
and they're like that might
be the top of their list
to have like physical connection with--
- I'm not a--
- Friends.
I'm not a hug instigator,
but I'm not an anti--
I'm not--
- No you're not...
- I'm not a anti I'm the anti-hug.
You, but you're not--
- I'm a hugger.
- So I'm a good hug receiver.
- Right.
- And like, I'm a good hug reciprocator.
- You're kind of neutral.
You can, I think you
can take it or leave it.
I think I could too.
No judgment here.
- Uh...
How was it?
- So given that you could take or leave
a hug in normal life, was it therapeutic?
Was there a release?
- I don't want--
- Or was it the same?
- I'm not gonna, I don't
want to be dramatic.
- Don't be dramatic.
I'm just saying--
- Be honest.
- Yeah, I'm saying that
I'm going to be honest
and say that it was really good,
but it wasn't like,
"Man, that feels good!"
"That feels different!"
That's like a giant step forward.
It did not feel that way for me,
it just felt, in fact, as we then sat down
and began to have a conversation
around the kitchen table
it began very quickly to
feel like old times again.
And I actually consciously
sort of stepped out
of the conversation and
went into my own head
and thought to myself,
like, "This is interesting,"
because I feel like
I'm totally here again.
Like I feel like the past
year is just a memory.
Now I know again, it's
going to be a slow process
of getting back to normal.
And I know this is not,
I say this, you know
being sensitive to the fact
that this is not the case
for a lot of people, but
it just kind of hit me.
I was like, "Hmm, I'm immediately back
"in the same mind space and social space
"and social experience that I
was before all this happened,
"like having this conversation."
But I could tell that not everyone
at that table felt the same way.
- And you should also
say who from my family
was or wasn't at that table.
So we began to talk about
you, because you and Christie
had also received the text
from this person to come over.
- Yep.
- And there was a conversation
and the conversation was,
they were like, "Are you thinking
"Link and Christie are coming?"
I was like, "Well"--
- This is between you and Jesse?
Are you already at the--
- Already at the table.
I was like, "Well, you
know, Link and Christie,
"they, the Neal-plan
may already be in effect
"and this may be difficult for
them to dislodge from this."
And then we had a conversation--
- And you pretty much
knew what that plan was.
- Well, and I'll just say
it's funny because, okay,
so it was, it was the McHargue's house.
And because Mike said,
"Well, here's the spectrum."
"On this end of the
spectrum in terms of..."
I can't remember the term he used,
but it was basically
like social flexibility
or something like that.
He was like, "You have the
Neals and the McHargues."
- Yup, they gather on one end.
- And at the opposite--
- Of the spectrum...
- Very socially inflexible.
- You have the McLaughlin's.
- And I was like, "Well,
let me butt in and say,
"That is true."
The McLaughlin's and the person
who was the guests there.
I was like, "That's true of my wife
"but I'm kind of in the middle."
I kind of straddled the fence on this one
because I will admit that
it was not easy for me
to just drop what my wanted to do
and watch a movie and come over.
I tend to kind of get into a plan.
And as soon as we finished
that conversation,
knock, knock, knock, your
wife and daughter show up,
but noticeably you're not there.
- Yeah.
(Rhett scoffs)
- So just to rewind a little bit.
Yeah, we're, we're sitting down like we,
it's eight o'clock-ish.
So all the Neal's without prompting now,
we all gather on, in
the TV room on the couch
and we put on "Survivor,"
every single night!
- Ooh well, on Friday
night you're having this?
- Even Friday night!
- Wow.
- I gave up a long time
ago on trying to like say,
"Yeah but on the weekends,
we're not doing "Survivor."
That's a weeknight thing on the weekends
we're going to do our own things
or we're going to watch movies
or it's gonna it's gonna
feel like a normal weekend,
not just like another night
like every single night
we watch "Survivor".
(Link guffaws)
- Friday nights?
- I mean, even,--
- With your kids?
- Even me, I was like,
"This is too much, guys."
And I lost, I lost the argument.
And then I was okay with that.
- Okay.
- And then months later
I'm really okay with it.
And then this, this one night,
it's like any other night
for the past year, we
look forward to this.
We relish in it.
If, you know, if anything breaks that up
just within the home, somebody gets mad.
You know?
It's like, if somebody is
not as into "WandaVision"
as the rest of the family,
introducing, like putting
"WandaVision" above "Survivor"
or, has been a problem.
- Yeah, how do you watch other things?
Or how do you watch movies?
- We double up, we don't watch movies.
(Rhett scoffs)
We watch, we watch--
- We don't watch movies,
I'll just be honest with you.
- If it's whatever's on
Disney + that we're all,
the new series that we're all gonna watch,
we watch that on Friday and then
we watch "Survivor" afterwards.
(Rhett laughing)
- It's ridiculous.
I know it is.
We're so extreme in this way--
- What're you gonna do, at this pace,
you're definitely gonna run out.
- We are halfway through
the Season 39 finale.
- How many seasons are there?
- 40.
- So you're getting
close to running out...
- And last night we, we paused it
at a strategic halfway point of the finale
because it was getting to
be, it's a school night.
It's getting to be bedtime.
And I'm like, "Guys, I
don't think we should go."
Like tomorrow night we're going to watch
the rest of the finale.
And then the next night,
I know you're going
to want to just start with season 40.
That's the last one.
And we've heard that it's
like the best season.
I don't want to go to it.
I want, I wanna wait.
(Link yells)
The complaining starts like,
"No dad, you're being crazy."
And it's like, there are some episodes,
seasons that we skipped.
I think we should delay the
gratification of Season 40
go back and watch some of the...
We're so into it.
Now let's watch some of the seasons
that people said sucked.
- Yeah, you've become dependent.
- We are dependent on
"Survivor" every single night--
- To survive.
- So I'm like, listen, we're going to blow
through season 40 in two weeks.
That's that's the pace we've been on.
- Yeah.
- We kept increasing.
I mean, it is this like
dependent compulsion,
leading to addiction kind of trajectory.
- You're going to have to
figure out some sort of--
- And I'm trying to point
that out to him last night.
I'm like, "Listen, guys,
we need to delay season 40,
"so that we can build it up
more and look forward to it."
Even if we skip three nights.
- Hmm.
- I wanna keep that Season
40 dangling out there
until it's closer to Season 41 coming out.
And then I'm also talking about when Lily
goes off to college, I'm like, you know,
what are we going to do with "Survivor?"
She's like, "We'll just
watch it and talk about it."
I was like, no, no, no.
We're gonna save "Survivor"
for holidays when we're all back together,
(Rhett scoffs)
and then we're gonna
watch those seasons.
This is how small my world is become.
- Yeah.
- Two weeks ago, we talked about
the wanting to look into communes.
It was very tongue in cheek
but it was rooted in
this feeling that I have
of I really liked the control
and the perceived, is
different kinds of safety
that has nothing to do
with COVID or pandemics
of just smallness of this
isn't this is my world now.
And this is, I know what to expect.
And it is fostering some
things that aren't healthy
and that are, this is what I discovered.
And this was, this is a moment.
It was a test.
We were sitting down and
then Christie looks up
and she's like, "Oh, we were invited over
"to the McConnaughts to see so-and-so."
And he's over there, now
he's fully vaccinated.
And she locks eyes with me.
And I bet if you were to ask
her what she saw in my eyes
I think it would be fear.
(Rhett laughing)
And it had nothing to do with the friend
or how much I love and miss him.
It was, and it wasn't just
about a threat to the routine,
but it was, things are changing.
Now we had already
planned to get together.
This was a Friday night.
We had already planned to get together
on Sunday night--
- Hm mm, at my house.
- And I was, I was getting
mentally prepared for that.
- Hmm.
- And then this was dropped in my lap
and I'm like, well you know, I was just,
I was getting ready for Sunday.
And now this thing right
now, right now, right now
and there were some mitigating
circumstances in our house.
I had actually just gotten the vaccine
the day before and experienced a headache.
And it, then I thought, I, I
felt totally good that day,
the second day, which
is the day in question.
And I went for a bike
ride when I got back,
the headache came back.
I did too much too soon on day two,
shouldn't have done that.
I actually didn't feel good.
And you know, there were
other members of the family.
You can figure it out by
matter of elimination that just
that were reticent for their own reasons.
So that led to, I'm going
to stay at home with them
and we can, we can blame it on the kids
but I have these things
going on inside of me.
And I don't know what's happening
in my brain and with my
emotions, but I just, I don't,
I'm not willing or ready to do this.
I'm not motivated enough to
overcome these feelings tonight.
I'm working forward to
being ready by Sunday.
And then I ended up, we watched "Survivor"
without Christie and Lily because
they gave us permission to
and I felt dirty and horrible.
- Oh my goodness!
- And I said, it didn't feel right.
And I don't want to ever do that again.
And then I went to bed
and my head was killing me
and I was so I was glad I wasn't there.
I wouldn't have, I wouldn't
have been a positive contributor
to that reunion, even though I hate
that I didn't get to see our friend.
And I, you know, I don't want him to think
that it had anything to
do with him specifically
but it really brought to light things
that I was just not
aware of at that moment.
And then, you know, so we're getting,
we can get back to the positives,
but we might as well go
through this anxiety
because that's what I s--
I never thought, I never had
what I would call "Social Anxiety."
I don't think.
It's so hard to remember.
- So you think that
that's what it is for you?
- Well--
- Like, okay,
maybe that's one way to describe it, but--
- What if you were invited
to, let's not just say
it's a get-together with
people that you've know
and you've seen a bunch, and
then one additional person
but an actual social thing.
Like a, like a party--
- Like I do, even when
we have, when you did
your monthly game night
and you had extent,
like more friends show up
for that, including us--
- Back in the day, pre-COVID?
- Pre-COVID.
There were sometimes I do notice
that there's a little
heightened level of anxiety
that I experienced, associated
with, even with that.
But some of it's just excitement
that can feel like anxiety.
So I didn't really know what was going on
but I would say that
there are plenty of times
that I'm not totally
at ease, even with like
my second tier friends that
like I trust and enjoy and love.
So there was an inkling
of that, that I recall
from pre-COVID.
But now on Sunday night,
when we got together
I got to tell you the thing
that you saw when you looked
around the table and you
could see in people's eyes
they were experiencing
something that you weren't
you felt totally normal
and maybe exhilarated
to be back together.
Even on Sunday night,
when we all got together
I actually felt when we left I
felt a little discouragement.
You know, there's a lot
of self judgment that I,
that tends to come into play with me,
but there's I'm a lot
more in my head right now,
because of this whole re-entry thing--
- You were--
- Than I even realized.
- I did notice that you
required quieter than normal.
- I felt weird, you know?
It was just like, because
it's a combination
of getting reintroduced
to something that I feel
like should be just
like flipping a switch.
- Well--
- But it wasn't,
and it wasn't anybody's fault.
And it wasn't, nobody did or said anything
to make me feel weird.
It was just, another part of it
might just be sheer unmet expectations.
You know, you build something
up and you look forward to it
then you, then you let go of it.
And then you realize it's
coming back and now there's fear
in the equation, but
you still have this hope
that like, this is going to be so dynamic.
This is going to be, I
mean, I never been to prison
but I would be interested
to talk to somebody
who has experienced re-entry from prison.
- It's probably a little more intense--
- More intense, but there's
a sliver of parallel,
at least, you know?
- I could tell, I made
note that multiple people
both on Friday night and on Sunday night
were not acting like themselves.
- Hm mm.
- And or what I remember of
them in those settings, right.
And I did notice that
about you, I was like,
"Link's being like, typically
he's very talkative.
Sometimes we have to pull
him back a little bit.
- Yeah.
- But that is not--
- And I really thought
I would have been that happy--
- But that's not happening.
- Especially with the prep.
I'd be like, I don't want
to come on too strong.
- And, but, okay.
But what I ended up
doing was after dinner,
we're all kind of like hanging out
and I needed to use the restroom.
So I went upstairs to use it.
And I will do this at most
get-togethers at my house.
I will go upstairs and then I'll be like,
I'm going to just hang here for a second.
But that was, and I did
that on Sunday night.
- You did disappear for a little bit.
- But I always do that
and always did that.
- It wasn't longer than I would believe
like an involved dump would take.
- I don't even think it was
a dump, I think I just--
- Oh, I know, I'm just saying--
- Think I had a pee.
- The amount of time that you took--
- Was under cover.
You gotta, you gotta,
you gotta keep in mind
you don't want to like,
draw attention to how long
you're in the bathroom, but it could,
people start thinking things.
They start assuming things,
but that's my introversion.
That's my, I got, okay,
I got time for people
and I got energy for people
then I have to pull it back.
But actually, as it was
happening, 'cause I'm also
in my own head a little bit.
I was like, am I having
like, my energy has been
impacted by this pandemic?
And I've got low capacity
for people right now?
Then I was like, no, no, no,
you're just an introvert.
And you did this before the pandemic.
- Hm mm.
- So I just kind of went back downstairs.
But in the midst of the conversation,
like, all right we're
having a conversation,
to me, I was also
thinking and noticing it.
I was like, I kind of
feel like I'm just back
where we left off but I can tell
that more than a few people
are not at that place
because our conversation feels different.
There are more gaps.
There's more like awkward--
- Why do we keep talking
about dogs so much?
Like, that's the thing I told Chrissy.
I was like, you know, I
was disappointed, like,
I kind of thought we would talk about
what we were experiencing, kind of what
we're talking about now.
I feel like I would've had a better time
if we could have just talked about that.
But maybe you talked about that
some on Friday night without us.
But we ended up talking about dogs
on four different times.
We were over here eating
and then we moved over here
and then we went inside
and it was just like,
we don't have as much to talk about.
We keep going back to dogs.
- I don't know--
- Was, that's what I--
- But, you also, you've
always attached expectations
to what conversations will be.
- Yep.
- That was, that's not a pandemic-thing.
That's a Link-thing.
There's many times, and this is sort
of a gripe between my wife and you.
This is like one of
the sources of conflict
between Jesse and you is like,
Jesse will start talking about something,
and you'll be like, "Ah, uh, can we,
"let's not talk about that right now?"
- Right.
- She normally not dogs.
(Rhett chuckles)
- Cause like I could have said,
I think legitimately, "Ah, you you know,
"we've talked about dogs
three times tonight."
I'm curious.
How are you guys doing?
Cause I feel weird as shit right now.
You know, it's like--
- Yeah.
- But I also didn't have the energy
and I didn't want to
do that at that moment.
But, uh,
(Link chuckles)
you know, I do own the, the
conversation police thing
because it is an outward manifestation
of my, my inner critic
and the control thing
that has to do with
expectations associated
with connecting with people.
Whether that, like the dynamics.
I think about it too much.
"Oh, who's included, who's interesting?"
Can we, you know, are
we... yeah, too much.
(Rhett chuckles)
Too much for people.
So on that piece of it, so yeah.
It's kind of like parsing what,
what's true of my former self?
What's new in the mix now,
what, this being a process, you know,
I even, I did a search because
I know that there's people
who are dealing with this more like,
and to a greater degree, there's
people who might've already
been agoraphobic or have
some sort of social anxiety
already that wasn't something
like me, that's like,
"Did I have that?"
- Yeah.
- Is that where this is coming from?
Nearly 50% of Americans say
they feel anxious about resuming
in-person interactions,
post-pandemic, according to a report
from the American
Psychological Association.
A phenomenon psychologists
have dubbed "Re-entry Anxiety,"
and Kiko, put an echo on that, thank you.
"Re-entry Anxiety."
(echo bouncing)
(crosstalk)
- I've heard of a lot of
people talking about it.
- I just want to go through this
and I don't wanna get bogged down in it,
but SCL Health, I think this
is like Colorado Hospital.
Doesn't matter.
Very practical advice to deal with
if you're, if you're struggling
with re-entry anxiety
just like a handful of things.
First, they say start small.
If you haven't left the house
in much over the last year
don't suddenly rip out the band-aid
and walk into the most crowded
marketplace you can find,
start small, plan a
hike with a few friends
work your way up from
there slowly confronting
your sources of fear, with a
little more exposure each time.
Exposure therapy is what
it's called by doctors.
This next point really
resonated with me, "Start soon."
If anything is making you anxious,
you should confront the
issue as soon as possible.
The longer you wait the
more the anxiety ferments
and works itself up.
So not only does social isolation
have short term health
implications that can impact
mental health long-term, it doesn't mean
you should throw a party
and you need to be subject to
the guidelines as we said up front.
But a little socialization
goes a long way.
You got to say, "I'm
engaging in this process
"of re-entry and I have to take baby steps
"and I need to start soon, or now.
Another another thing
was, piece of advice was
"Looking at the big picture."
A good thing to do is to ask yourself,
"What truly makes me happy."
And whether that's family, the outdoors,
returning back to life,
let the big picture be a major motivator
to overcome the fears
in comparison to them,
in combating reasons
to not start or delay.
You know, I was gearing up for Sunday.
I wasn't ready for Friday.
I listened to myself and you know
but if there wasn't a Sunday plan, I'd,
I might would've felt differently now
about my decision to not go on Friday.
- Hm mm.
- And then two more things, buddy up,
find someone you know and
trust who's in a similar phase
or has a similar experience
and understands you
that you can buddy up with
and support each other
through the re-entry
process, talking about it.
I mean, even this
conversation is freeing for me
because it's like, "Hey, you've heard
"what's inside of my head."
I've kind of given you this emotional
brain-dump so to speak.
So it's, I think the next time we're like,
if it's next weekend, that
we're in a small group setting,
there might be an opportunity
for you to say something
to me or me to say
something to somebody else
who's opened up to me, that type of thing,
you know, I think it really helps.
And then yeah, they, they note in the end
for some people it's going to be a breeze
like the way you described
it could potentially,
I could experience jealousy
or envy or, or beat myself up
because it's not as easy
for me as it is for you.
And that's no fault of yours.
And this is my responsibility to process
that in a way that doesn't, you know
drive a wedge between us and
somehow then send a message
that you can't enjoy
your re-entry experience.
That's not--
- Well it remains to be seen--
- That's not fair to you.
- Well it remains to be seen as well as--
- Oh, but hold on.
I just wanted to make one...
But the main point I was trying to make
that they were making at the end was
if you come to a roadblock,
you can seek out help.
That's beyond just a friend, you know,
a professional--
- Yeah!
- Help to get you through this.
And ain't no shame in that.
What were you gonna say?
- I think the thing that I am,
I'm not going to be
surprised if I experienced
some anxiety, I'm interested
to see, is a big crowd.
Like if we're going to a basketball game
and there's a herd of people
going through the small door
and then they're all crowded together.
Like I can only assume that
when that kind of thing
starts happening more and more often,
so not socially distance, large gatherings
people packed into places,
people at concerts.
- Yeah.
- People are going to panic.
You know, I think the
reasons for the anxiety,
they may not be rational,
but a lot of them
they probably come from different places.
Like I can imagine that--
- Sure.
- One of them is just
like, I'm seeing a lot
of people close to me, touching things.
I'm watching their mouth move...
- Oh gosh, the mouths!
Just the scene of mouths--
- People touching things.
And so if that's something
that you struggle with
is just the idea of the,
the germs of it all,
the humanity of it all.
- Yeah.
- Then that could be something.
And then it just may be,
oh, a social anxiety.
I don't know how to say the words
that I used to say when I meet people,
but that whole surrounded by people,
I'm not saying I anticipate
it's going to be a problem.
But if, to me, I feel
like if I'm going to have
an anxiety issue, I doubt
that it's going to be with
my friends that I see on
a pretty regular basis
but it might be in a group of strangers.
Like that could be where something like,
"Oh, all of a sudden this,
this is such a new experience."
And again, I mean, I guess there...
It depends on where
you're at in the world.
you're at in the country.
These are, I'm sure there
are people listening
to this podcast who are in
States where they're like
"Ah, it's kinda just been the
same for a long time for us,"
guys are like, "You guys are
crazy and California is nuts."
- We're proud and we're
affirming their decisions--
- Yeah!
- All along the way.
And it's like, "Well,
we're not trying to affirm
"your decision if you didn't,
if you didn't lock down
"or wear a mask or whatever."
- But uh...
- Yeah.
- So yeah, when it comes to parties,
like with friends I'm
committed to like getting back
to that magic spot but
then like then beyond that,
like, okay, 'cause to
me it's, it's not about
catching anything or exposure or the like,
I dunno, I don't worry about that.
It is the social thing.
And like, it's just like
getting reacquainted with that.
So it was like the parties
with strangers, sorry.
Oh yeah.
It's like I was on the fence about
how much I enjoyed that beforehand, so--
- Well, that's the thing
that's kind of odd to me
is we, you know, we've done
we've done at least an episode of the show
about our approach to Hollywood parties.
And I'm not talking about
the Fauci-parties where
I drink the children's blood.
I'm talking about like industry parties,
where you dress up and you have cocktails
and their music is too loud.
Both neither of us have ever been a fan
of those kinds of parties
because of the whole,
I can't have a conversation
with you right now.
Cause I can't hear you
because of the music
and I, is this for clout
or what is the reason
I'm walking around this party?
Who am I trying to talk to?
Am I trying to tell John
Mayer that I love him?
Or I might just trying to meet somebody
that I might work with...
And--
- Both.
- As we've established,
you tend to be comfortable
with being like, well,
I'm just going to go
up to a little Dicky and
start a conversation.
And I'm like, well, I'll let
you go up the little Dickie
and start a conversation.
And then once you're in,
I'll come and join it, right?
As we hilariously told the story one time.
But interestingly, it's so
funny that the whole story
about little Dicky
involves him telling you
that his name is Dave.
And now the show that he
makes, is just called Dave.
(Rhet laughing)
- Yeah.
- The way that it play, every time I see
that show advertised, I just
think about that story, but--
- I can't bring myself to
watch it for that reason.
- I, my prediction is that
everyone's going to have
some latent sort of anxiety in this.
And again, I, I'm not I'm not minimizing,
there's people who are really struggling
and this is a serious thing
and they are going to need
to get professional help.
I understand that, that's not my scenario.
That's not my situation.
And I have empathy for the
people who are going through it.
But I think that
everybody is going to have
there's going to be
awkwardness when you go back
to that party with the music
and the talking to each other
which was already difficult
for everyone involved,
even though we tend to not
talk about how difficult it is.
Throw in the fact that like,
"I haven't been in an
environment this loud
"let alone with this many people"!
When that ha--
My hope is that out of a, in
an effort to kind of help us
all ease back in, that
the DJ will be like,
"Man, I'm going to go a
little easy on these people."
- I'm telling you--
- You know what I'm saying?
Cause I just think that
there's so much opportunity
for parties to be transformed.
I mean, we did a whole chapter of this
in "The Book of Mythicality," about how
we didn't like loud parties.
I just feel like there's
an opportunity here
to not just go back to the bullshit party
where you can't hear anybody.
- Yeah, I got more thoughts
on this that relate
to something else that
we've been talking about
and laying groundwork for...
- But you're not going
to bring it up now--
- No.
- You're thinking of
bringing it up later--
- I'm just telling you so that
we won't forget to talk about it--
- Oh!
- Later.
Another, you know, I talked
about the prison and prisoner
being released-analogy, but
it's also thinking about
like an astronaut who's been
in the International Space
Station for like a year and
then they come back to Earth
and they're like, even
though they've worked out
and everything and they've stayed healthy
and they've been focused on
what it is they've got to do,
then they come back to this world
and all the gravity
takes its toll you know?
And it, it takes a while
to like even figure out how
to physically walk properly.
I think?
Doesn't that happen.
- I'm sure, yeah.
Depends on how long you've been up there.
- And relate to people, you know?
And so I'd be interested to see
what they're saying about that.
I'd take a, there is an
astronaut masterclass
but I don't think it's related to this.
- A masterclass?
- Yeah, so I'm interested in one of those.
Let's bring on an astronaut to talk about
how to re-enter the world socially.
- Not sure that...
Oh, well, okay.
If he, if he makes the
connection to that, yeah.
- Okay. Or she, women can be Astronauts.
- That's true.
If they make the connection to that.
- There we go!
(Link chuckles)
- So,
this is just kind of
put in a capper
at least this is how I hope
we're rounding a corner
that like, you know there's
not going to be any,
we don't have to return
to any type of lockdown.
I don't even want to talk about that.
I'm hoping this is a bookend
on an experience that
if you, if you go back
and listen to our conversations,
as we were entering into it
we were thinking of things like,
"Okay, we're living history."
There are opportunities
associated with this.
Let's embrace this moment for what it is.
Let's be as responsible
and healthy as possible
but let's also embrace
the experience of it.
So when we're done with
it we have lessons from it
and we can move forward.
I'm not ready to say that yet
because we're realizing
that we're still having...
The re-entry is an
experience in and of itself
that I want to have that mentality
of "I'm embracing this moment by moment
"as part of history
and giving myself grace
to be on that process of reentry."
That it it's okay that
it's not flipping a switch
for every single person.
And that we're not on the same pace
but we are on pretty
much the same trajectory
of moving past this and
the ones that we love,
some of them need an extra hand
or a little more understanding,
more patience to get there.
- Well I think the fact that a lot of us,
a lot more people can relate,
people like you, as an example
that wouldn't have said
that you had any sort of
social anxiety who are like,
"Is this what I'm experiencing now?"
I think a large number of
people experiencing that,
is a great opportunity
for more people to relate
to those who had social anxiety disorders
before the pandemic started.
- And to astronauts.
- So we can, you know,
never hurts to have a little
more empathy in the world and to have
those conversations about
other people's perspectives.
- Yeah, it's my rec.
Imma give it to you.
I recommend this week that you
go through your old shoes--
- Hmm.
- Put on a pair of shoes you haven't worn
since the beginning of pandemic, you know
you got those shoes that are in the,
you shoved them to the back of somewhere
and you're like, "I'll bring
these out for something"
I'm not necessarily
talking about dress shoes.
It doesn't matter.
Whatever.
Walk a mile in someone else's shoes.
That's someone else
being your former self.
I think it's, I don't know.
It's just like a practical,
physical, active embodiment
of reconnecting with your former self.
And then after walking
in those shoes all day
you realize why you haven't
worn them in a year.
And it has nothing to
do with the pandemic.
Then either give them to Goodwill
or if they're really horrible,
just throw them away.
And let it go.
- Hmm.
- And consider it an act of embodiment,
an exercise in remembering
your former self
but also deciding that
you're not obligated
to still be that person moving forward.
Maybe there's things you wanna change.
You're looking at my shoes.
- I was thinking you were
like wearing like a different,
I haven't seen you wear a
different pair of shoes.
- I don't take the advice I give.
Oh, okay.
(Rhett chuckles)
(upbeat music)
- Walk a mile in someone else's shoes.
- I think is good advice.
I think there's a third option--
- Do it!
- That somebody just
told me about 'cause I,
cause I have a tendency
to go through all my
old clothes and shoes.
- Yeah?
- And then donate all of them
which I think that that is,
priority number one is to donate.
But somebody said, you know
you should save some
stuff that's more notable
and indicative of the time period
because your kids will want
to wear it at some point
or want to be like this
is my dad's old shirt
from 20 years ago.
These are my dad's
shoes from 20 years ago.
And I think that there's that again,
I give away most of it
but keep a few pieces as
memorabilia for your children.
Somebody just gave me that advice.
And I don't remember who it was,
but I was like, that's a good idea
because I don't have, like I think about
the stuff that I wore in college
and I see it in these pictures, but like,
it'd be cool if I could be like,
"Look, here's the shirt
I wore in college."
"You're wanna wear in college?"
(Rhett chuckles)
Or just do you want it
just as a piece of history?
- So keep 'em,
(Rhett laughs)
for that reason.
- No, give away most of them
- Keep some of them...
- The experiences is
the more important part?
- You're right.
- It's not really about what
you do with them afterwards.
- It just hit me, you know?
- Okay, all right.
- #EarBiscuits, let us
know what you think.
What's your experience on re-entry?
- And I am, genuinely interested
if there's anybody who, what
I had to say about vaccines
made you think something
new and different.
I would, I continue to be interested
in being able to be a force for good.
And I want to know if I just
pissed a bunch of people off,
didn't change anybody's
mind, or if you're like,
"Oh, actually I'm going to do this now."
I just, from my own personal data points
let me know or just tell
me why, why I'm wrong.
I'm also very open to that.
#EarBiscuits.
- [Link] To watch more "EarBiscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of EarBiscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical Best.
(upbeat music concludes)